european union ministers responsible for
energy policy aim this week to agree on
new rules to make the use of biofuels in
the eu more sustainable and so help cut
greenhouse gas emissions
the council wants to finalize its
position on so-called indirect land use
change this is when farmland is used to
produce biofuels leading to food or feed
being grown in other areas like forests
which results in more carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere the aim is to minimize
the environmental impact of indirect
land use and encourage more advanced
biofuels onto the market
also on the agenda the ministers are set
to endorse a report on progress made
toward completing europe's internal
energy market by next year's target days
the report addresses aspects like the
development of energy infrastructure
ensuring investments energy efficiency
and pricing
the council is also likely to endorse a
second report on the external dimension
of eu energy policy it covers
developments in the global energy
landscape in recent years progress made
in eu policies in this domain and looks
at ways to strengthen them